e
bonjour
d'abord je suis très content et très
honoré d'être ici je remercie les
organisateurs d'avoir pensé un invité
avant de vous raconter un peu le
parcours de comment je suis arrivé -
enfants de la classe de tir il a réalisé
ce documentaire sur notre mémoire
pluriel je vous laisse regarder un petit
extrait merci mais je n'ai aucune
collection non à milly lamartine à mâcon
m'a mis la vie de la nation
oui à nassim tombé à l'art de la marine
la gamme je n'oublie et comme chalon oui
quand j'écris ici la mc mais lula les
audois buisson les poulains de kamel et
je suis là cela d'anaheim
il ta peau d'un moine assument des
moutons adam un seul cas de la dame a
dit fish et juan riise gravelines chaque
numéro les eaux
alors cette famille à côte que j'ai
rencontré un petit peu par hasard en
faisant ce tournage parce que vous savez
que dans le documentaire
il ya à la fois ce qu'on prépare en
fiction de la réalité mais il ya aussi
ces moments le réel qui vous explose en
pleine figure
j'avais mis juste en scène ma recherche
de conan niniches mouyal qui est la
séquence suivante et j'ai proposé à mon
chef opérateur à mon caméraman de
d'aller voir d'aller faire un micro
trottoir est de savoir ce aux femmes
on savait je savais que j'étais dans une
ville majoritairement marocaine et on
savait pas sur qui on allait tomber et
je suis tombé sur ce trésor de femmes
qui racontent un petit pan de cette
histoire du maroc j'ai voulu raconter
dans le film alors comment est née tout
ça moi je suis originaire de tignes rire
alors je sais pas si vous savez où ça se
trouve c'est dans le sud-est marocain
entre ouarzazate et errachidia c'est un
1500 m d'altitude dans une des plus
belles vallées du monde je dis ça en
toute objectivité carmaux caméraman m'a
dit c était un des plus bel endroit
qu'il n'avait jamais visité
je suis né dans le coeur historique de
cette ville et c'est important parce que
ça a été pour moi ma principale source
d'inspiration
je suis né dans une maison en terre il y
avait 1 puis il y avait d une étable il
y avait cette cuisine berbère avec ce
four en terre cuite déambuler dans ces
ruelles pour moi a été pendant toute mon
enfance a été quelque chose de da c'est
magique parce que l'odeur particulière
notamment quand il levait de la terre et
de et de cette maison de et de se taire
de vin et de la terre ces maisons en
terre de pisé il y avait il y avait là y
avait une odeur particulière
j'ai pas vécu très longtemps mais j'y
retournais chaque été j'ai quitté tignes
rire à l'âge de 6 mois mon papa était
ouvrier en france depuis 1968 et il
décide de nous faire venir par
regroupement familial donc j'avais six
mois je quitte le maroc mais j'y reviens
très souvent mes parents ont gardé un
attachement extrêmement important où
chaque été nous faisons ces aller-retour
ou venez passer l'été au maroc et donc
pendant toute mon enfance mon
adolescence je passais la plupart de
l'année en france et l'été j'étais at-il
rire au maroc et je crois que ces
va-et-vient ces allers-retours m'ont
fait poser beaucoup de questions sur qui
j'étais est-ce que je suis français
parce que pour les français jettent et
marocains pour les marocains j'étais un
français et pour moi c'est cet entre
deux fragiles a été pour moi aussi une
une source de questionnement et
d'interrogations que j'ai voulu que j'ai
voulu approfondir j'ai voulu savoir d'où
je venais j'ai voulu comprendre un petit
peu plus l'histoire de mon pays et donc
finalement je me sentais comme une
espèce d'étrangeté à la fois à distance
entre momas ma culture marocaine et ma
culture française que j'étais en train
de d'acquérir progressivement
évidemment ce sentiment et q7 conscience
aiguë de que des différents sentiments
d'appartenance nous conduit à faire des
études d'histoire j'aimais beaucoup
écouté mon grand-père l'âme obama grand
mère me raconter ces périodes de ciba
ces moments de l'histoire du maroc que
j'ignorais totalement donc le maroc qui
n'était jamais très loin je fais mes
études en sorbonne et je fais un devoir
enfin je fais un mémoire de maîtrise sur
la dynastie des idrissides m'assurer
idriss 1 et driss deux qui étaient les
plus connus mais plutôt sur ses fils qui
s'entretuent et qui était une période
qui était beaucoup moins beaucoup moins
étudiée
suite à cela un retour un grand père
avait l'habitude de nous d'organiser un
grand dîner avec toute la famille et ils
commencent à me raconter son ancienne
vie quand ils travaillent en algérie
quand il a travaillé en espagne en
france et là tout d'un coup il me parle
de ses amis david est moche et et david
est moche et de tin rires donc j'ai
voulu en savoir plus parce que pour moi
dans ma tête de marocains de culture
musulmane
vous pouvez appeler que ali et mustapha
houamed et lyle commence à me raconter
qu'il y avait une présence juive
extrêmement importante at in rire est là
pour moi ça m'a ouvert je pense des
perspectives tout d'un coup j'ai
découvert pour pouvait être comme
marocain est aussi autre chose
pas seulement de culture de culture
musulmane et j'ai voulu et très vite
j'ai j'ai une empathie pour ces
communautés qui avaient tous quittés qui
avaient tous les est derrière eux cette
absence m'habiter cette perte
j'étais un peu orphelin de cette
présence que je n'avais pas connu mais
que j'ai j'avais envie de retrouver en
tout cas par par les vivres par les
photos que j'ai pu retrouver après et
j'ai voulu comprendre comment quitte sa
terre comme on quitte les hauteurs de
son enfance pourquoi et comment survit à
l'arrachement à ses amis à sa maison à
sa famille à son imaginaire à ses
auteurs et chaque été donc j'ai
interrogé mes grands parents et j'ai
voulu un moment donné reprendre mes
études d'histoire oui parce qu'après je
suis devenu j'ai enseigné d'histoire
pendant dix ans et j'ai voulu reprendre
mes études à la sorbonne et j'ai décidé
de faire un sujet sur une communauté
juive berbère attin rire et donc je vais
à nantes
retrouvez des archives je vais à
jérusalem je vais à paris je vais à
rabat je retourne à t-il rires je
questionne les anciens sur ce passé
commun
donc j'avais envie de faire plutôt un
travail scientifique ce que je
maîtrisais en premier lieu et je décide
d'apprendre l'hébreu je m'inscris dans
une association qui s'appelle parlait en
paix où on apprend l'arabe et l'hébreu
instant parce que vous savez que ce sont
deux langues sémitiques shalom salam
chef shemesh voilà de l'anc soeurs
issues de l'araméen aux mêmes racines
j'ai voulu connaître je me rend
plusieurs fois en palestine en israël
pour essayer de retrouver ses anciens et
pendant ce voyage qu'organise parlait en
paix je rencontre un peu par hasard
enfin signe du destin le maktoub
quelqu'un de mon village quelqu'un dont
la mère des parents et qui parlait
encore le plat déjà venait devenait de
tinghir et là ça a été pour moi un
déclic je me suis dit qu'il fallait que
je fasse un film qu'il fallait que je
raconte cette histoire car le groupe qui
était avec moi était extrêmement ému de
voir deux alter ego l'un juif et l'autre
musulman se retrouver après 50 ans de
séparation et de brisures et donc je me
suis lancé comme un fou tout le monde me
disait mais comment tu vas pouvoir
retrouver toute cette communauté ont
dispersé et toi tu n'es pas signer ainsi
tu n'as pas fait d'école de cinéma suis
historien et la 1 g je suis allé quand
même j'ai écris parce que le désir était
là parce que c'était vital pour moi nous
raconter cette histoire avant que ces
anciens disparaissent et évidemment ça
pas été de tout repos ça m'a pris quatre
ans de réaliser ce bébé est innée à
jérusalem qui circulent aujourd'hui dans
le monde entier et je me suis posé
évidemment plein de fois des questions
de légitimité
je me suis réveillé en sueur pendant un
tournage pendant oui le lendemain où je
me disais ce que mon personnage va
toujours accepté d'être interviewé j'ai
eu peur de réaliser d'accoucher de cette
oeuvre aussi mais je crois que le désir
et il ya vraiment un message à faire
passer ce seuil est le moteur de la vie
c'est ce qui donne aussi un sens à notre
existence
je crois qu'on peut pas imaginer le
voyage que ça a été pour moi personnel
intérieur de voyager avec ses anciens
juifs et musulmans des deux côtés qui me
racontait les mêmes histoires qui me
chantait les mêmes champs et j'ai voulu
aussi donner à ces à masirah ces
berbères aussi une dignité parce que
pendant longtemps ils ont été mes prises
et marginalisés et pour moi dire que ce
n'était pas du folklore dire que ces
gens avaient aussi quelque chose à nous
raconter à nous la nouvelle génération
de se passer de bouc grand but de
l'histoire du maroc j'ai voulu
finalement reconstituer un puzzle le fil
d'une histoire interrompue
j'ai voulu recréer ce monde disparu par
la parole par ces témoignages pour
marquer à jamais pour que les gens ne
soient pas amnésiques de se passer en
commun et on le voit dans le film ils
n'ont pas oublié la davie ja il chante
encore en berbère ils pratiquent encore
le i douce et je crois que c'est ce qui
a marqué beaucoup les téléspectateurs
évidemment ce film a changé ma vie
il est passé sur 2m en prime time plus
de trois millions de marocains regarde
ce film le 8 avril 2012
et là le soir même où j'étais en train
de regarder aussi mon film avec quelques
amis à casablanca
je reçois des des centaines de messages
des coups de téléphone de journalistes
qui voulaient absolument faire une
interview le lendemain dans la rue
j'étais reconnu les gens me disent bravo
nous aussi dans mon village à des mots
tizié qu'on avait aussi notre communauté
hélas le film va commencer une carrière
dont je ne soupçonnais pas parce que
quand vous faites un projet aussi
difficile soit il on ne sait pas ce qui
va se passer après on sait pas comment
il va être accueilli hélas le paroxysme
effectivement de ce beau voyage en tout
cas avec ce film va et étrangers
polémique évidemment des opposants des
gens qui estiment que ce film était un
film sioniste qui voulaient normaliser
avec les méchants alors que moi je
racontais tout simplement l'histoire une
partie de l'histoire du maroc et que ces
gens étaient partis en papouasie juste
répartis aussi en partie les interroger
et je crois que je n'avais pas
conscience et tant mieux d'avoir brisé
un tabou d'avoir offert en tout cas aux
marocains un miroir de leur pluralité de
leur altérité
hélas le film continue à new york à
montréal à san francisco en jamaïque en
israël en europe un peu partout
comme ça dans le filage eux la potée où
ce genre de projet c'est tous ces
visages que j'ai pu rencontrer ces juifs
et musulmans mais aussi des gens qui
n'ont rien à voir avec cette culture et
qui finalement ont été touchés par cette
thématique de la perte de l'absence de
des retrouvailles autour de la de cette
mémoire commune de cette mémoire
plurielle et je crois qu si les
personnages simples émouvant des gens
qui n'ont pas eu la chance de faire de
grandes études mais qui vous parle des
maisons vides avec des métaphores qui
vous parle de l'absence de la terre de
l'arrachement à la terre avec poésie
avec beaucoup de brio et je crois que
mon grand-père lac molinie yacout qui
nous a quittés eux aussi sont des
personnages qui vivent encore en moi et
qui m'inspirent et qui nous disent
quelque chose de ce que nous avons été
scud de ce que nous sommes aujourd'hui
puisque la dernière constitution
marocaine reconnaît notre pluralité le
stum musulmans arabes juifs africain
méditerranéen andalous se sont toutes
les identités qui constitue le peuple
marocain et on doit être fier et j'ai
pas fini cette aventure parce que j'ai
voulu pendant ans présentement ce film
un peu partout dans le monde j'ai
rencontré aussi la troisième génération
j'ai voulu savoir si cette troisième
génération avait aussi envie de
perpétuer cette mémoire de transmettre
mémoire aux nouveaux jeunes et là je
rencontre un groupe incroyable à
jérusalem qui chante en d'elijah ils ont
30 ans il chante samuel marly biseau
grêle facile
selim al ahly on va en écouter un
morceau tout à l'heure
et pour eux c'est important d'avoir un
passeport marocain c'est important
d'avoir une identité marocaine affirmé
ils sont ce centre avant tout marocains
vont se sentir autre chose hélas débute
un nouveau film un film autour de retour
au pays natal parce que moi j'ai fait un
film sur le départ et j'ai décidé de
revenir vivre au maroc à marrakech et
pour moi ce qui est important et ce qui
me motive c'est aussi la dimension
politique au sens noble du terme créer
du lien créé du stand créer des repères
vivre ces moments de partage et de
fraternité
ensemble pour moi ces artistes nous les
artistes nous sommes je crois décor
politique en puissance qui disent qu'ils
qui en tout cas arrivent à faire éclater
toutes ses appartenances identitaires et
à essayer en tout cas tant bien que mal
à les faire vivre ensemble
pour moi faire ces films continuer à
aller interroger à les questionner les
questions société du maroc se défendre
un maroc fier de ses identités multiples
plurielle et pour moi je crois que c'est
la meilleure arme contre les discours
obscurantiste partager transmettre
contre les discours extrémistes et c'est
pour ça qu'il est important
le combat que nous avons à mener
aujourd'hui c'est inscrire toutes ces
identités plurielles dans les programmes
scolaires afin que nos jeunes ne soient
pas amnésique et soient fiers et pour
eux que ce soit une arme de combat
effectivement contre tous ceux qui
veulent faire oublier qu'ils nous sommes
réellement tout mon travail c'est aussi
de questionner la place
c'est quoi notre maison c'est quoi notre
lieu c'est quoi nos identités
c'est à dire que l'identité toujours
quelque chose en construction d'une
identité émouvante une identité elle et
elle est toujours en rapport avec
l'autre
finalement après tim rf jérusalem ce
travail m'a permis de les tremper avec
toutes mes identités multiples je suis
marocain français musulmans de culture
berbère amazigh et sont deux peut-être
aussi un peu juif
j'ai dû finalement passer par la figure
de ce juge absent pour me retrouver
c'est seulement quand j'étais face à mon
grand père à ma grand-mère et mas bas
que j'ai pris conscience de la douce
venait de ma culture amazighe des
montagnes parce que quand on vit en
france je vivais dans un environnement
extrêmement français dans la france
profonde et c'est pour ça que je parlais
de voyage dans le temps et que tu as été
pour moi une source d'inspiration que je
retourne je suis maladivement amoureux
de ma ville non pas au sens nationaliste
mon sens poétique et n'oubliez pas de
choses avant de passer à cet extrait on
a besoin de l'autre pour savoir qu'il en
est et le désir rend possible
l'impossible
merci